people of the internet retrorecontour
here and
guess what guys it is finally
time you've been asking for it i've been
getting questions on twitter comments on
youtube
prisoner of azkaban let's play
where is it
it's finally here and you're about to
watch the first episode so why is it
taking so long well unfortunately this
game does not run well at all
on dolphin which is what i've been using
to play the other game so you're gonna
actually if you've watched my previous
chamber of secrets let's play you're
going to go into this one and think wow
that actually looks a lot worse graphics
wise and that's because it does not run
well on dolphin so instead i'm going to
have to play this on the original
hardware so i've got a nintendo wii
so it should be like the progressive
scan i think 480p
right 40p uh the video you'll be
watching will be 1080 but trust me
you're going to see it's really really
blurry but that almost kind of adds to
the charm a little bit when you look
back and see just how far these games
have come so if you're kind of watching
these in order though and you think whoa
the graphics here really took a step
back
it's not anything to do with the game
itself it's mainly because chamber of
secrets runs really well on the dolphin
emulator so you can turn up like all the
effects and run it at high resolution
that sort of thing but as far as
prisoner of azkaban goes i do not have
many memories of this game which i think
is going to make this for even more of
an interesting let's play because i
can't remember it i know i played it i
don't know if i beat it as a kid
but i definitely played it so what to
see as i go through there how much i'm
able to remember but it's definitely
going to be like a fresh experience for
me because
i i remember so little about it so hope
you guys enjoy this episode one and i
will talk to you again very soon if you
enjoyed the video don't forget to give
that thumbs up
all right people here we go jumping in
with a fresh save got my wave bird
controller here man this is still to
this day one of my favorite controllers
of all time so we are diving in now to
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
for the nintendo gamecube of course that
means this is the console version of
prisoner of azkaban this is also uh on
pc developed by no wonder here we go
to 13 people with a single so we're
starting in right right on the train
heading to hogwarts
wow you can really tell with the
graphics too big change in the graphics
a lot more like the movie counterparts
gotta help them find scabbers
and we are officially in control
all right gonna go ahead and move the
camera right off since uh i want you
guys to be able to see the little uh
menu there
wow you could just see right away how
big of a difference the
uh dolphin emulator works man whenever
you can run
gamecube games on dolphin
it's just amazing how much better you
can make them look so
we're getting all the blurriness and all
the blockiness with the prisoner of
azkaban but again that i think that does
kind of add a little bit to the
the old school nature of it
monster book of monsters
oh whoa whoa whoa game is chugging
already okay pull and hold r to target
an opponent and then press x to castle
pindo oh i really do not like holding r
i just feel like
whoa
i feel like l should be locked on i'm
just so used to l locking on in games
how many times am i supposed to do this
yeah i am ron
are you blind are you not seeing this
it's like yelling at me castle pindo
dude are you not seeing me castle pindo
oh my goodness wait the camera is come
on harry give me a hammer no way
oh can i not oh please
please let me change it
no you can't change the camera
oh my gosh you guys this is a sign of
the times man
so like when i press
left oh this is so ridiculous
it's like inverted horizontal
which is ridiculous
oh man
i'm not i'm just going to try not to
move the camera at all i guess
let's see it is it kind of okay so it
does follow you a little bit
hopefully that'll be enough
the controls are a very kind of loose
feeling
like he does not control very precisely
at all
not nearly as responsive as chamber of
secrets
all right what do i need to do ron are
we doing this the old-fashioned way we
just learned when guardium leviosa my
friend
we learned that year one why are we here
in
now okay put it down let's go and fight
why are we here in year three
uh lifting it by hand
all right want to find scabbers now i
just heard a chocolate frog
i cast it on this box right here
oh yes you can there he is
you're a little chocolate frog
dude this you want to see a sign of the
times like look how few
options you actually have you have
flying control center screen rumble and
subtitles that's it
like i wish i could remap
uh
so so l is the lock on instead of r but
hey
it's okay we'll get to this i know a lot
of you love this game and hopefully i
will i will love it in due time as well
once we get past the controls i should
have known this pathetic excuse for a
rat had something to do with you
give him back now foy or what with a
black mouth
richter
you are whoa
oh oh we're doing this we're doing this
right now okay pull and hold r to target
and then press x
oh my goodness the game is chugging
the game is chugging the frame rate is
so bad
dodge
what i'm a pumpkin
what is this
wow
dude the frame rate is so bad
why didn't i turn into a pumpkin at that
time
there we go there we
you go
hit the side of a barn weasley
oh again now it's malfoy
yes
yeah now you know oh that one i saw the
curse that time
it had the pumpkin head as it was flying
at me okay now ron's telling me to get
out of the way okay fine fine over here
it doesn't look like you'd charge up
like you could in uh previous chamber
secrets at least not yet
[Music]
come on ron
uh we just want the rat back malfoy
if only malfoy knew dude
this is so different from the books
this is so different
wait what
dude maybe i did never play this game
because i don't remember any of this
what's happening
i mean i know dementor obviously but
just pass out right there
it's right there
come on ron do something
wait
oh i thought it was it's like am i
actually going to play as ron
oh we are
oh my goodness he's got to drag him out
oh
anything i can do to speed this up
i've got to move harry away yeah yeah
i'm trying
can you not see
ron
we're moving we're almost out of here
okay now what now where do we go
just keep backing up i guess i've got to
move harry away from that dude what is
what is with this man oh no
we go
repeatedly to break free
okay oh it's like
we have to maneuver around all this
stuff
dude that's creepy
the resident evil glass break right
there
spoilers resident evil one you guys
haven't played that
what are you doing if you haven't played
that one yet
okay finally
harry harry
are you all right
what are you okay
yeah
what happened
who screamed no one screamed but i heard
screaming yeah eat it it'll help what
was that
a dementor it'll
are you sure you're okay harry
fine
take this book harry
i'm sure it'll help
what has a few pages missing but i'm
sure you'll be able to find them ah is
that gonna teach us the patronus charm
okay
at long last the hogwarts express
reached its destination and soon harry
and his friends were safely in
gryffindor tower
knowing that sirius black was likely to
be looking for him troubled harry deeply
and professor dumbledore's announcement
about dementors patrolling the gates
while sirius black was still at large
only confirmed his fears
but finding himself back in the familiar
dormitory
harry felt he was home at last moment
last did you have a look at the folio
brew tie that lupin gave you then
folio brutai
come on let's have a look at it then
show it to me what the heck
come on show me the photo time
to show the folio brewtite iran press z
to go to the inventory i remember folio
magi in previous games
uh folio universitas
challenge scores
let's take a look at the menu here we've
got
looks like maybe some wigan weld potion
vials birdy bop beans got a quest page
up here
uh looks like we are going to be playing
harry ron and hermione because we've got
all three of them over here on the right
show the folio brew okay so it'll show
you a list of your tasks see i like this
but man this like this game is uh
hopefully it kind of smooths out as we
go but it is not running it's wicked
well at all i have to find the rest of
those pages oh that's cool so it's like
a little log book for
creatures that's awesome man hogwarts
legacy i i think with this the much
focuses they have placed on magical
creatures
surely there's going to be a compendium
or something to where as you go
you're going to be able to
keep a log of all the creatures and
stuff that you meet okay so i wonder why
it's not showing up as one of five right
there
folio brew tie
yeah so that's the only one i have right
now so oh wait let's read it let's read
the little entry the guards of azkaban
prison dementors are among the foulest
creatures that walk this earth
they didn't even talk about what they
actually do though come on
all right z to return to the adventure
let's go show it to hermione oh dude i
just like i can't use i can't use the
camera stick
because it's just so
it's just so bad
oh
what's in there great hey wizard cards
are back
nice
complete collector's card sets for extra
rewards let's go all right where do i
see the wizard cards probably not there
probably going to be right in here
show the folio yeah we already did that
okay
challenge oh wait where would they be
there we go
okay so the wizard cards are folio
universitas
cyprian yaodel i believe is how it's
pronounced
1312-1357 only quidditch referee i
remember this guy i remember this guy
from the other game uh only quidditch
referee to ever be killed during a match
the originator of the curse was never
caught but believed to have been a
member of the crowd yeah okay now this
is a big step down though you guys like
it doesn't even show you the actual card
like you don't get a picture of him or
any okay
did you have to press a again i was
about to say that is ridiculous
so you get like the little text there
and then you press a again to get the
the blown up version of it right there
all right let's back up
press z to return the adventure
man everything's just so slow uh-huh
you can move the camera around yeah i
know but i can't change it
why why was this ever a thing to make
the camera like i understand inverting
of the vertical controls
but inverting horizontal that's so weird
i think it's like animal crossing does
that when you're inside the house but
that one i at least understand because
it's sort of like you're controlling
like a
you're like inside the house and i guess
it's more to be like a camera moving
around where i guess technically this is
a camera too but still i don't like it
anywhere it should give me the option to
change it
all right so that's kind of weird that
it has to load are you serious it has to
load the sorry i'm reading okay maybe
just because of the cut scene so much
work to do
but you knew you said you had lots of
trouble with draco on the train oh yeah
yes
well you could have made it so much
easier for yourself with the
expelliarmus spell
harry's go to spell
thanks i'm interested to see if they
changed it up from the last game do you
remember the last game expelliarmus was
like really like what protego is
supposed to be or much closer to what
potato is supposed to be
dick's belly armor spell
oh you just you just remembered all of a
sudden harry
oh you read the book okay perfect okay
so this all looks uh very similar but
you can tell like they've changed some
things i wonder if we still have the
notice board nice lost a prefect badge
last seen in the entrance hall if found
please return to this notice board see
like i will already say man the menus
not nearly as slick
as they are in in chamber of secrets
it's kind of weird like i would love to
do a deep dive on this whole
series and kind of how these games were
developed because
so many different developers involved
[Music]
wait so when you do l that actually
tells ron like hey come over here
all right what did hermione even tell me
to do
wait what this looks completely
different now
oh i can equip a new spell all right
let's put expelliarmus on b disarming
charm repel spells back at an opponent
yeah so i think it's going to be
exactly like it was in the last game
x or y too quick say what i can't put it
on b or a
okay
like three vials here and what maybe
two four more spells
it's kind of weird all right that'd be a
step down practice expelliarmus with ron
on the seventh floor okay
but yeah like how with how many
developers were involved and how they
had to rush
every year except when the movies would
like have a little gap
then they would have to rush to get the
game out it's just it's just really
weird to look back on the development
cycle for these games and i would love
to do
a deep dive interview i mean i don't
even know where all those people work
these days who worked on these games
like they're probably in so many
different places now
um but i would just love to hear more
about the behind the scenes and i'll try
and use expelliarmus okay come on
just right in front of the fat lady
oh yeah dodged it that time ron
now it's my turn
i'll cast rupendo at you and you use
expelliarmus to knock my spells away all
right we gotta figure out the timing
here three
two
one
kinda the same you sort of have to hold
it a little bit
yes
actually the timing might be a little
bit more forgiving in this one let me
try it again i'm going to wait for it
oh yeah timing is really more forgiving
in this in this game hey i've got an
idea let's go and see fred and george
let's do it are they in there uh
are they in their little hideaway
oh wait can i still get birdie bop beans
out of these things yes we can
can you lock onto them though no
oh you don't get nearly as many beans
either okay where are fred and george
ron that's the question
north wing looks like it's locked
i mean are they possibly back here
seventh floor of course
you didn't even tell me where they are
dude
where are they are they in the common
room maybe it tells me in here
[Music]
uh on the sixth floor okay perfect see
ron like that's the kind of information
that would have been helpful dude
that's that's
sort of important here
the fat ladies corridor okay
okay now see all of this
oh wow it is laid out completely
different
completely different from chamber of
secrets so yeah that's that's the only
direction we can go right now
in chamber of secrets remember you could
like you would go this way to head to
the main staircase all right so we were
going the right way let's go ahead and
go back through here at least like it's
kind of annoying that there's that
little brief loading screen between
doors but
at least it is brief it's it's very
quick
so i think they're trying to make it
easy on us right now because they're
locking the doors where we're not
supposed to go so you see that one's
locked this one's already open so
they're like hey george on the sixth
floor okay now he finally says
oh sir
now that is pretty cool
i like that
i really like that that's a that's
definitely a welcome addition like so
far i'm kind of like ah
chamber of secrets i feel like it has
more overall polish
but again
uh a part of that is also because of the
fact that it runs so well on on the
dolphin emulator but um but i do really
like that
and if you look closely you can see his
his mouth is actually moving so they
they do have the moving portrait for him
all right let's go ahead and go through
here
grand staircase
all right i spoke too soon about the
loading because for that one it did it
did have some loading right there
but i will skip that for you so you guys
don't have to see every single loading
screen
all right six floor ancient runes okay
now this looks
it's it's different from the last game
oh my goodness wait can i not just go
all the way down
hey peeves what's up dude
what's it to you well if you're gonna be
like that here's a little bedtime story
this is a boss fight already a peeves
mini boss fight
oh it is dude it actually is
whoa wait what am i supposed to do
[Music]
i'm trying to like
i'm watching like the pink that goes
flying
there we go
[Music]
there's so much flying around i'm like
wait what am i supposed to actually be
blocking
all right the book
the book's health bar is almost depleted
why is that not hitting him
oh he's like kind of
i think i missed i just didn't hit those
couple of them
right let's go and find fred and george
oh geez
you really know how to cast that
experiment spell
inside joke there you really know how to
get
did ron know the was he reading the
future right there of how important that
spell was gonna become to harry wait can
i not open this okay there you gotta get
just a little bit closer
chocolate frog maybe
no oh another wizard card let's go
[Music]
all right let's take a look at that
wizard card oh man i gotta get used to
don't hit start hit z here
all right and let's go to the page with
the wizard cards
and another quidditch one
wait i was like that's who i already got
uh jocelyn
wadcock
1911 a present chaser for puddle mere
united quidditch team record for highest
number of goals during british season
this century against bally castle bats
in 1931
and there she is right there
all right who did it say she played for
again puddle mirror united quidditch
team
all right let's go back to the adventure
there we go z all right
now i heard a chocolate frog too
oh my goodness the camera try casting
spells on objects they can provide extra
stamina
what ron calm down oh this box right
here
and chocolate frog where are you
come on out buddy
wait what
wait
there he goes you have to fully break it
okay
and then you just walk over him you
don't have to cast a pendo on him like
you did in one of the games
oh let's get going
dude i can already tell like that the
backtracking of this game is going to be
way much more
annoying
because of the fact that i can't go down
all of the stairs you have to go
it looks like it requires you to go
through each floor so when i open this
door i'll skip it for you guys but i'm
going to have a loading screen
and 10 minutes later in real time no i'm
just kidding it wasn't that long but
yeah that's it's gonna be it's gonna
take a little getting used to
when he's there again another frog
glanmore peaks corridor now see that one
required no loading at all dude look at
this
look at this
what is that is that dude i wonder if
that's meant to be the basilisk
no it's got like let's get going shall
we
got like a horn on the front or
something maybe a dragon
uh looks like we have some broken glass
right here
oh the attacking books man we can't get
away from the attacking books run harry
dude do you like have to lock on in this
one right you know what ron let's just
go
let's just go
dis used bathroom is that what it said
disused
ah here they are
so it is a similar like george what are
you going to show us
they're in a similar place just get
there
so there's an entrance to a secret
passage in here yes indeed there is
young harry and we're sure that one of
you will be able to find it
all right i'm ready oh wait the secret
passage is in here you can swap control
between harry and ron by pressing b
hey there's something odd about that
wait what just happened
i had to switch to ron for him
no surely harry could open it too
but can i get by you guys or
maybe it's like a switch or something i
have to
activate maybe
we're standing right beside the passage
just come here and look at the wall
surely you can see it okay let like can
i get by
you literally just have to walk by and
press a
gentleman
oh my goodness man
okay let's go i'm gonna switch back to
harry now oh
i thought i messed something up for a
second
yeah come way down here
oh fred george
now see this i could believe i could
believe that they would like make some
elaborate challenge only hermione'd fit
through there
only hermione could fit through there
or get surely he said get
get through there
oh my goodness but yeah i can see fred
george coming up with an elaborate
challenge like this
before they give the uh
before they give the map to you more
pretty about beans
yeah i mean just like early early
impressions like this game needed so
much more polish
it needed so much more polish
all right but let's see there's got to
be a way is that is that safe lopindo on
there looks like some sort of animal
like a paw print
can i just pick this up
oh my goodness i gotta switch to ron
don't i
now this is kind of cool i do like this
i do like how you're you're gonna work
as a team in this one there's a gap
under that
okay
wait maybe he did actually say only
hermione can fit through there do i have
to like go back and get hermione
i'm not going in there
i'll leave that to hermione i'll leave
that term dude hermione's not here
are you seriously gonna make me go all
the way let me look and see what the
instructions say if it has a
find the marauders map
okay wait maybe okay
maybe we could do this without
maybe this is just like for something
extra over here we don't have to do this
right now
all right i'm just gonna try i'm just
gonna try to yeah okay i didn't think so
you guys learned aloha mora come on why
have you forgotten it all right i mean i
guess dude i guess we have to go back
and get hermione
those that dare to take them okay
so weird like the progression
wait now where are we
now
where the heck are we
okay this was not in the book
i don't remember this this isn't going
to be easy make harry leap over a gap
run him at the edge and he will
automatically jump across okay
can i make that jump though
like does harry have those kind of hops
let's find out
watch it he did okay
and it goes into like a brief cutscene
ron saying watch it
watch it harry
wait what was that
collect more pages to complete your
folio brew tie okay i don't really know
yet whatever you do don't mess up
collect challenge shields to earn extra
house points okay that's kind of
cool that switch harry can you get to it
yep i got it wicket
uh to move harry along narrow ledges
push him up against the wall and then
move him sideways along the edge
oh wait did it say clock
[Music]
okay i'm glad he can grab onto the ledge
thankful for that
all right now what do we do just go back
[Music]
now can we just jump over here
there we go
open up the door right behind ron
cornish pixies
freshly caught cordish pixies
i don't know if these are fresh they're
probably left over from here too
oh no
[Music]
what else am i going to okay i
appreciate the humor in this one wrong
i appreciate your humor
search room for objects that may help uh
no how about i just like flip into all
of them
how about that
oh my gosh i thought i fell
yeah what does it mean search for
objects that may help
what else could i need besides the good
flapindo charm
a flapindo charm in the hands of harry
potter okay ron's just like
appreciate it walks off that's it
okay let me see here i want to see if it
added anything to the folio brew tie
no i guess you collect like pieces of it
or something
uh but i did collect something about a
challenge
dueling club owl racing and hippogriff
flight
okay that's a nice tease
very interested to learn more about that
and then can i like click on the shield
yeah so we've earned 10 house points
extra house points
i'm gonna check this one too just to
make sure yeah i didn't think i'd gotten
any more of those
all right let's go back here
gather these birdie bop beans
wait what are you doing in here ron
what is what is this
what
oh man the instructions in this game
okay all of the buttons
yeah they've all been pressed
there's nothing else we can do with that
let's see if it's search the room for
objects that may help
we need my help
oh maybe i have to go to ron
is ron the only one who can
the old weasley touch
all right so apparently is that like us
meant to be a special ability of ron in
this game that
he finds hidden passages must work too
friends must work together okay yeah so
maybe it is like maybe you have to they
want you to switch back and forth
i was thinking that all the controls
were pretty much the same for them but
i guess not i guess they do have
different abilities that they can use
all right i probably should have paid
attention to what they were showing me
there
yeah i'm not moving the camera because
you guys have a
an inverted camera
all right i think we're gonna need to
move this over here
wait
wait wait wait i wanna pick up
i wanna pick up i want to pick
up
my own can you help me well to call your
friends come on over here ron let's get
this
and i guess i was thinking we were
supposed to move it to a different spot
but the way the camera is
positioning
i think it's clear where they want us to
go
oh wow
oh wait maybe not like maybe
did he say there must be a way to that
mirror yeah so let's go over here
we're probably gonna have to move this a
couple of times
now see i love stuff like this
moving boxes
no no but like climbing onto a trunk can
be a good way of getting to otherwise
unreachable ledges no like i love the
you gotta remember when this game came
out right
a lot of this stuff hadn't been done to
death as much as it has nowadays
um but yeah i like the idea of like
having the trio work together
if the controls were a little bit more
you know precise i think it would be i
think it'll be better more fun okay
search rooms for objects that may help
clearly we're going to have to play
around with the light here
and the question is do we have to
actually move anything okay step on
let's see what happens here we step on
that
oh yeah it's like zelda style puzzle
right here let's go
all right so i think we want to what we
want to do is turn that one yep
where face is there
nice right onto the eye
all right now we're gonna have to push
the trunk back that way
unless maybe they can just hop up there
all right this is how you know if
they're just totally trolling you or not
like it should just let me hop up but if
it doesn't let me hop up that's just a
complete troll okay good
i was gonna be so annoyed if we had to
go and pull the trunk back over search
the room for objects that may help wait
what collect challenge shields why do
why do you think i need help again
aren't we good or haven't we got
everything we need to here
dude i'm probably missing a lot of
secrets aren't i you guys that have
played the game comment below
let me know how many secrets i've missed
so far
ron's like upset about the puzzles
another puzzle oh
great all right
interesting
you know what let's just
just spam a for pindo on it
and then i bet one of us is gonna have
to
i want to see if harry can interact with
it or if it's only ron wait try
harry's like harry can't do it okay
let's switch to ron
dude so it actually is a thing
ron is the only one who can
open the hidden passages
all right i'll take a couple beans there
one more bean
bertie bots every flavor beans
[Music]
oh goodness a pixie
oh they're already gone
there you got the other one or he flew
off
oh wait i don't know if we can get rid
of them permanently
anything else in there i don't think so
how about over here ron
i love how they like try to play it off
as
what do they say the old weasley touch
or something like what
oh like it's some special ability that's
been
passed down in ron's family for
generations
to open secret passages
oh goodness i mean his brothers do have
the marauders map so
uh but they weren't the creators of the
marauders map that's one thing that's
pretty unfortunate about hogwarts legacy
man is like the marauders map is just
such a great
navigation system
for for a harry potter game but it just
wasn't out it wasn't created yet
no don't fall in the hole geez i didn't
notice this over here
late 1800s yeah it wouldn't have been
there dude more pixies okay
boom direct hit
see dizzy automatically fly off or do i
have to hit him again
okay i think harry did something as well
all right so are there any more of those
secret passages
that ron can unlock doesn't look like it
okay here's what i think has to happen
let's stand up here
and then have harry
oh i was gonna try to castle pindo on it
the other way but maybe it's
something to do with that one over there
can you get out there hurry
what no of course not
how would i get up there maybe can i do
this manually like if i walk up to it
search the room for objects that may
help do you want me to wait get up here
with you yeah i don't think that's gonna
do anything press a to grab the rope
i really don't like this place
see i had no idea he could climb the
rope
oh my goodness look at this
make sure you don't fall off thanks for
your concern ron
oh jeez okay i do appreciate the humor
ron just like
this is not the type of thing that
somebody would want to be like have
someone coaching them through it
just just be very quiet dude very quiet
wait you know what is there another one
behind me
come on lock on to it lock on to it
all right perfect
okay now
do i just drop down oh yeah there's the
rope there
i didn't see it
actually just kind of stumbled right on
no
search the room for objects that may
help well i hope it's not a secret
passage
since harry doesn't have the ability to
open hogwarts secret passages anymore
it's only for ron
know that help is always at hand for
every truth be true mischief maker
all right
it's like it's like a play on the uh
dumbledore's line about the sorting hat
help will always be given at hogwarts to
those now
ah here we go okay so they brought back
that mechanic as well
dude what
what is up with the monster book of
monsters being it's the third time we've
faced one as an enemy which is
absolutely hilarious to me
[Music]
it's like do we have to wait for the
mouth to open maybe
oh dodge harry
yeah
no
wait i thought his health was gone okay
it is and now he's all chill
you're supposed to stroke it
stroke the spine of course all right oh
wait i can talk to that portrait let's
go
sue boy
what is the password
wait who are you
sir boy
what is that who are you
and where are you leading is that
slytherin
pretty sure slytherin was the only other
common room to use a
password system
feeding owl treats to hedwig allows you
to control her and perform tasks for
harry okay
because uh
ravenclaw you had to answer the riddle
and then hufflepuff
you had to um
oh man what was it you had to do with
hufflepuff
i think you just had to tap like a
certain brick
i believe or tickle the pear
i think tickle the pair something else
[Music]
or maybe it is maybe it is the
something like that for hufflepuff
hufflepuffs was the same every time i
remember it wasn't like a riddle that
changed or a password that changed oh
wait we are in control of hedwig now
oh i don't know how i feel about
so wait these controls
are inverted
which kind of feels normal for flight
oh goodness
oh you gotta break hedwig's gotta bring
the map back
hold on i'm gonna change it really quick
just because i wanna see
line controls let's change it to reverse
i think i do like inverted on the flight
i solemnly swear
yes marauders map here we go
obviously plays a big role in the
prisoner of azkaban book and did i just
see an extra 10 points for gryffindor
randomly appear oh now we got the little
mini map top left that's awesome
surreptitiousness
oh
please wait how does he know the
password
excuse me
and another i'm going to leave that in
i'm not even going to edit it out i'm
just going to leave the sneeze in avoid
being seen okay wait hold up can i view
my map by pressing z here
let's see what does it say now find the
marauders map well i've got it dude i've
got it
oh there we go you can look at the map
okay now i'm curious what those two
little
blue circles are now you don't have any
control like i can't move the map at all
that's kind of annoying
[Music]
and it's supposed to tell me names
what's up with that
i love how the map just apparently gives
you oh wait can i not get back through
i don't think i can
the map apparently like told me the
password somehow
right can i not like creep like slowly
walk
dude is this actually slytherin i don't
know where i'm at
what is this
i don't want to move the camera around
because of your garbage system
your garbage camera controls
is that it oh no there's another one oh
we got it we got to go the other way
because i bet we have to press that
button
like does he actually care how slowly i
walk by
or do i just have to like stay out of
that cone of vision
because if you remember in the other
game like you actually have to be quiet
or the prefix will
oh wait no you don't i think it is just
line of sight
this feels like it's definitely a line
of sight for this game cause i was just
running around
as long as i'm out of that cone
so like to do this little like kind of
sidestep i'm just holding r down
now they want you to go this way
i'm just gonna full sprint
just don't even slow down here oh wait
what is this
oh dude i bet if ron we're here that's a
secret passage
that's secret passage ron could access
for us
and we're by okay
and another 10 points dude what is
i thought it was a dementor for a second
stand in the shadows to avoid being seen
there are no shadows what are you
talking about
there's light everywhere i get what they
mean though i get it i get it don't
worry
oh now this one though wait a second
wait a second
where am i supposed to go
this is just like pass right in front of
him
no i'm not
oh geez okay i was like how far back
does it put me
all right hold on there's gotta be
something that i
didn't mean to do that
it's gotta be something i missed i think
if i look to the left right here
oh yeah let's go like all the way up
here
and then right here oh just a chest
though
i mean i'm glad to find the chest but i
actually thought that was gonna be the
way by
for one bean get out of here
okay so it's definitely just like
literally that single cone nothing else
this one i am baffled though
like i obviously i could follow it but
when he turns back he's gonna see me
see can i jump up top maybe
[Music]
does lapindo do anything
maybe i just like
missed it the first time
like it's not even giving me like now i
can't even get the controls to
my goodness
the fact that the controls are reversed
it's so baffling
all right wait was there a spot over
here i missed if i can like sneak by
like sneak to the left no something
maybe there's like a little crack there
oh and you can't even go back so this is
definitely the way that i have to go
like i wonder if i just like oh you can
like
oh
that's clever
that's clever i was thinking man like
there's no other way to go
it has to be
now see this one
throwing another curveball at you here
because
oh i see what you got to do on this one
here i can go right in here
hug the wall hug the wall
and go here we
go all right now don't think i'm gonna
miss that little hallway right down here
let's see what's in here maybe another
chest
oh two chest
glad we stopped for that
dude should i have sent ron on this
journey instead because look at this
another spot where it looks like
yeah i was like can i press b now can i
call for him ron come to me
i tried pressing l by the way nothing
happened
dude are you serious man
the chests hold a single bean each
get out of here man get out of here it's
garbage
oh
that's professor snape
that's professor snape so not only do we
have to worry about the
sentries
in the suits of armor here now we also
have
professor severus snape to deal with
yeah let's hug that
and then run out
oh goodness don't do that don't do that
can we hug this wall yes we can
i don't want to move the camera
i'm just going to watch this guy
okay wait a second can i just go right
behind him
i know if it will let me go behind him
let's go
oh geez wait what do i do here
oh there he goes
come on hug the wall harry
dude i'm i'm so tempted to castle pindo
press open the door
like in a modern game i'm so getting
caught right there
it's brilliant
but in this game it's like i know if i
could press a it's gonna let me through
we're sure to have something of interest
and at a very reasonable price
oh geez
flashing your task list and see what it
means
so dude hey look you remember was
flashing
i wonder if we can get back to that spot
remember where it's like only hermione
could fit through there
surely it's gonna come back
done everything we needed let's go all
right well let me make sure there's not
anything else in this room when you want
to go on to the next day press z to go
to the task list and press a to activate
the end date option okay very cool
so now like could i
could i roam hogwarts freely or
it's the east wing here
oh goodness i forgot about those things
what is that
it's weird that i can lock onto it wait
is that supposed to be like the
oh it's like the little scourge
the stuff you have to clean up in the
other game
all right guys that was a great first
episode hope you enjoyed it as well if
so don't forget to leave a thumbs up on
the video before you go episode 2 will
be on the way soon now that i've got
everything set up ready to roll
they'll be coming out a lot quicker
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon